23rd start for freeland
you see the numbers basically a three to
one strikeout to walk ratio he's gonna
be disappointed that the season's over
in a week
easy play for cj crone one out
that ball driven out to right center
carries really well out to that part of
this yard one hops the arm and hammer
and that's exactly what escobar did to
freeland right there
now he's hit safely 13 of his last 14
ball games the conundrum that is trying
to pitch to juan soto
1-1 to the 22-year-old and that'll be an
easy play again for chrome
one-on-one on zimmerman
and this is
top to short
trevor to crow and a good start for kyle
freeland he got three groud balls
31st start of the season for patrick
last start on the 23rd against the reds
got the w after six and two thirds
shutout on four hits struck out seven
239 hampson's batting average
corbin on the slider in the dirt block
by ruiz the tag strikeout number 135 for
patrick
by keeping everything down
foul tipped picked cleanly by ruiz
two up two down on strikes teams have
really come inside frequently on story
got out front a little bit here high fly
ball to shallow left field
and it's going to drop
and stories can end up at second left
field doesn't see it off the bat it's
twilight so once he goes above the
lights which it did it's really hard to
pick up
well he's got him swinging at that low
slider
he's going to strike out the side ruiz
to zimmerman that's it for the rockies
after a blue double
this is a chance for two story one flip
over the raptors well done
there's that ever present
ground ball double play with kyle
freeland needs it most
you go from two on nobody out to a
runner at third and two gone
one two
and that's great pitching by kyle
freeland
undaunted by the traffic he gets a
strike out of garcia after the double
play ball
mcmahon 02.
best ball right in there
ryan mcmahon looked like he was
expecting something off speed breaking
away
and every out's been a strikeout so far
fastball hit hard
that gives you a lot of time to turn a
double play
6-4-3
and while we like strikeouts we really
like double plays that gets corbin and
his buddies right back into the dunk
ryan zimmerman will lead off the top of
the fourth against kyle freeland
who fastball turns it around
off the wall just feet from a homer
and zimmerman into second base on an
absolute rocket to left center
who kicks and fires pitches hit in the
air
shallow left field hilliard coming on
now underneath it makes the catch and no
way zimmerman can tag on that sam
hilliard or maybe 20 feet from the
infield dirt when he makes that catch
two down
glide ball shallow left good jump from
hilliard and once again freeland works
out a little bit of traffic
ryan mcmahon to try and cash in at least
one of the base runners he swings and
drives the ball to left center field
that's going to drop for a hit coming
home
back heading to second is it with a
double
one-nothing rockies
[ __ ] strike three called on the outside
corner
kyle freeland gets his second strikeout
to to the count to rogers here
well placed hits the plate corbin makes
the turn what a play and that's about as
good as it gets for a pitcher defending
going over the shoulder you have no idea
where first base is right here so he
makes the over the shoulder catch gets
rid of it all in one motion
to a stretching ryan zimmerman trevor's
story a double in two tries
deep center field
take a good look you won't see it for
long
story
touch of all time
trevor's story
two
nothing rockies
man oh man he is still fun to watch
475
feet to center field this is full of
nationals
two-nothing colorado in the top of the
seven
[Applause]
off the
plate forces in a run
so nice
applause for the crowd tonight as kyle
walks off 2-1
bases remain loaded
key boom at third
josh bell at second lane thomas at first
facing tyler kindly
and he's going to get him
shallow center
[Applause]
hamson is there in the inning
two hits two walks the second walk
forced in a run
this ball spoke to deep right center
field
hops the wall rivals
infield stays in with just one out tapia
third
rogers 0 for three tonight
this should get it done it may get over
the head of soto it does
toppia walks home rogers in the second
with a double make it 3-1 colorado
2-2 and there's a double play ball
there's one
there's the second third double play
turn tonight by the rockies another
strong strong inning
so carlos estevez has completed his
warm-up pitches and he'll get ready to
steer down yadiel hernandez
leading off the ninth and it's carter
kibum and luis garcia
there's a double play ball
[Applause]
[Music]
and garcia this is not a double play
while you would think the way he runs
but he got to end the game and the
rockies win three to one
[Music]